this is from patron Demonte ward where
everyone in the room has becoming
successful influence who you are in a
positive or a negative way what is the
question again Devante Demonte Demonte
is that her okay ward for everyone in
the room who has becoming success it's
it's like this I used to work at arrest
Sears no one's gonna get a restaurant
called the Brockton bill very sad I know
and I would go ten minutes before my
shift
mhm I'd go on I'd say hi to the manager
you know hug some of the Busboys Jesus
yeah no I know now but back up what's up
dude you know min and then someone will
tell me like what section I mean or what
not right oh yeah and you have this
these people you work with it's the same
thing in comedy right you go to the
comedy club and you see Eric Griffin
I'll slap his ass I'll go over to Thea
what's up dude you know me and do that
whole thing to me I I haven't changed it
doesn't feel like so you feel like it's
affected you positively only I don't
think it's a positive negative I just
think that I'm just living a life and
but but at the same time you know if I'm
at a restaurant I don't feel differently
at a restaurant I don't think so no net
gain I don't think there was anything
that give to you what's all good
nothing I don't know I'm thinking like I
mean I think it's just a little bit you
know I guess it's kind of spooky you
know like in some ways if what does the
question again say that he's grounded to
get me I know you're doing his thing but
it's okay I cannot remember the question
you would do it again Devante war where
everyone through which is inane that
someone obviously made up before I got
has becoming successful influenced you
who you are in a positive or negative
way if so how it's a good question to
montt a demon for surety well thanks for
the question Demonte what I'm saying is
this I don't know man I think it's very
scary I think you know being successful
can be very scary because I think that
like your ego can be very scary you know
yeah so that for me is like very it's
really really spooky and so for me I you
know I feel like it's just a little bit
scary you know it's like okay well if
I'm getting more successful like you
know you just I don't know it seems like
a sometimes a lot of pressure but also
you know sometimes I feel confident
about it like I want to you know go
achieve my dreams or whatever my goals
are and other times I feel like scared
about it so I think some of that's
normal but that's kind of what I think
about it I think it's a bigger change
when you see guys that start and then
they shoot up quickly
yeah because for me I've always been at
this light level of kind of a kind of
people know who I am yeah so I've been
like this for 20 years since mad right
so I was on a show that's when when it
first started it was cool I'd go to this
West Covina Bob said this before just to
get recognized oh yeah yeah yeah and it
felt good but it never went above that
level right it's always been and then
there was times a couple years there
when I didn't work that much and it died
down and then you have to accept that I
didn't know it's kind of getting back to
you know the level that I'm was used to
which is very polite people everyone so
I the other day we're driving some guy
took a photo yeah weird things like that
game in you yeah yeah gay men yeah but
yeah I don't think so not for me you
know I think you haven't changed yeah I
feel more stressed out but I think most
that's just more work
you know gonna used to be able to not
have to really think about that much
work and just have to not think about
that much and I got more stuff to think
about mm-hmm and so it's exciting but
it's also it's kind of stressful hmm but
some of its transition period you know
so I have to recognize that and just be
patient with myself